翻訳: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
日本の小学校に通うブラジル人の女の子に
名前を尋ねたことがあります
「学校の名前を知りたいの？
本当の名前を知りたいの？」
という質問が返ってきました
その意味は みなさんわかりますか？
実は ブラジル人が日本の学校に通う時に
保護者は「名前どうしますか？」と
よく尋ねられます
私のように少し長い名前は 短くすること
また日本式にすることを
薦められることがあります
私の名前で言うと
リリアン・テルミ・ハタノではなく
ハタノ・テルミと呼ばれることがあります
在日外国人が日本式の名前を名乗る[方が]
馴染みやすいと思われているようです
子ども達[は]知らないうちに
学校で慣れ親しんだその名前でしか
自分の名前を書けないようになります
親や家族につけられた名前を
使わないようになって
それに慣れていきます
「学校の名前を知りたいの？
本当の名前を知りたいの？」
というのは そういう背景があったのです
日本の社会では均一性が大変重視[され]
「違う」ことが嫌がられることがあります
どうも均一性の中にいると安心できるようで
その外国籍の名前も日本式にしていくことを
推奨されてしまう背景があります
本当に これは自然なことなんでしょうか？
私は日本に来たのが1993年
阪神淡路大震災の2年前になりますけれども
当時 ちょうど日系ブラジル人が
より良い生活環境を求めて
日本に来ていた時期と重なります
その子どもたちは日本の学校に行き
どのように日本語を習得していくのか
もしくは学校でどうやって受け入れていくのか
というのが知りたくてその調査をしに
日本に留学にきました
その学校にいた子ども達というのは
当初は小学校 中学校を中退し
高等学校に進学しようと思っても
夢のまた夢と思う子ども達がいました
外国籍の子ども達の居場所も必要だなと
思っていた頃でもあるんですけれども
仲間と一緒にボランティアグループを
立ち上げることになりました
そのボランティアグループは
今16年目になりますけれども
当初は日本語指導 日本語学習
今や逆に日本語しか話せない子ども達
世代交代しているので
日本語しか話せないブラジル人の子ども達に
ポルトガル語を
継承語としてのポルトガル語を教えています
そもそも外国籍の子ども達は
日本の義務教育[の]対象にされていないことを
みなさんご存知でしたか？
それはどういう意味かと言うと
外国籍の子ども達は学校へ行かなくてもいい
教育を受けなくてもいいと[いう]
考えがあるように[思え]ます
外国籍の[子ども達が]義務教育の対象に
されていないということは
その子ども達にとっての教育プログラムに
なっていないということに[なります]
例えば公立学校に通うと
日本人として教育していくということが
前提になっていくんですけれども
モノカルチャーを追求する場所なんです
そこは
多様な背景を持った子ども達が
じきにどんどん慣れてきて
その自分の力を発揮して
最大限に発揮して
いろんな知識とか力を身につけていく場所には
残念ながら今はなっていません
学校に早く馴染むことが
最優先課題とされていきます
その結果日本語が話せない
子ども達というのは
日本語を話せるようになっていくと同時に
日本語が話せない親との
コミュニケーションが成り立たない
というような状況ができています
その多様性を発揮するような教育に
なっていないということが
私は問題だと思います
では 公立学校に馴染めない子ども達は
どうすればいいのか？
どういう選択肢があるのか？
ということになりますけれども
実は日本にはブラジル学校が存在します
ご存知でしたか？
その親の夜勤や日勤の時間に
合わせて対応するために
そのブラジル学校は早いところは朝5時から
遅いところは[夜]９時まで子ども達を預けて
託児所のように子ども達の受け皿になって
発展してきました
そのブラジル学校は
年々増えていきましたけれども
経済低迷が起きた時に
ブラジル人自身が
31万[人]いたんですけれど
17万[人]まで減っていきました
それと同時に
全国で100校あったブラジル学校が今半減
半分無くなってしまいました
良いこともそのブラジル学校にはあります
先ほど言った日本の公立学校と違い
日本語しか話せない
ブラジル人が育つのと違い
親とのコミュニケーションは保てる
全教科ポルトガル語で
学ぶことができますので
親もその教育に参加していくことができます
でも実際にその子ども達が
ブラジル学校を卒業して
いつかブラジルに帰れば問題ないんですが
日本に定住していこうと思った時には
やはり非常に限定した機会
非常に限定したチャンスというのが
子ども達を待っていることに
なるんではないで[しょうか]
全ての子ども達の教育環境を整備し
充実させるということは
様々な日本の批准した国際条約に
批准した国々が義務づけられる
そのことが十分に守られていないと
いうことになるかと思います
学校に行けない子ども達が
どうすればいいのか？
その子ども達の教育を受ける権利は
どうするのかということになりますけれども
基本的に多様性を認めるというような
方向性にならない限りは
なかなか難しいところがあると思います
要するに 多様な子ども達に合った教育
というのが
保証されることが望まれると思います
子ども達の背景に配慮した
教育が必要だと思います
それはどのようなものなのかというのを
みなさんと一緒に考えていきたいことなんです
さて じゃあ問題はその子ども達が
ブラジル学校に行けば済むのか？
ということになるんですけれども
残念ながら話は[そう]単純ではないんです
伝統的な日本の学校に
慣れない子ども達というのは
外国籍の子ども達だけではないんです
フリースクールに通う
日本国籍の子ども達もたくさんいます
全国で12万人の子ども達が通っています
均一な教育に馴染めないというのは
外国籍の子ども達だけではなくて
日本国籍の子ども達でもいます
多様な文化をもった人間に触れずに
均一化した教育を受けた子ども達が
自分と他者との違いの中に
いろいろと自分と見つめ合って
成長していくというチャンスに
恵まれないことになってしまいますけれども
自分が何者なのか問いかけるチャンスも
少なくなってしまいます
大学生に向けて授業をしていますと
よく「日本はモノカルチャーだ
単一民族だ」と耳にします
本当にそうでしょうか？
決してそうではないと思いますし
それは間違いだと思っています
みなさんもご存知のように
日本にはアイヌ民族 琉球民族などや
在日朝鮮人をはじめとする
多くの外国籍の人たちが
日本で生活基盤を持っています
そもそも民族や国籍以前に
今みなさんの隣にいる人たち
みなさんの隣人のことを考えても
みんな違う人間ではありませんか？
違いがそれぞれあって
当たり前の話なんですけども
周囲の多様性に気づけば
その多様性が溢れています
残念ながら 多くの場合は
それに気づかないで生活しています
自分と他者の違いを認めるということが
できないような状況というのは
どうでしょうか？
均一性を信じ込んで
人との間に違いを感じるということは
中には不安を覚える人もいるようです
でも実際に考えた時に
みなさんの歴史を振り返ってみてほしいのです
実はこの神戸からは
明治時代から多くの日本人が
いろんな国々に渡っていきました
私の出身であるブラジル[や]
アメリカ 中南米各国 フィリピンなど
様々な国に渡っていきました
その子孫 その家族が
今でも世界各国で生活しています
何世代も 様々な職業に就いて
様々な生き方をしています
同じように世界各国から
神戸もそうですけれど
神戸から旅立った人たちもいれば
様々な国から日本に来て
生活している人たちもいます
このように均一性というものは
ありもしない幻想だと思っています
誰もが多様性の中にいます
多様性がないようにしようとすると
やはりいじめとか不登校とかに結びつくような
要因になっていくのではないでしょうか？
違っていることを弱みだと思わないで
強みだと思える社会を
一緒に作っていきませんか？
（拍手）
自分と同じだと思い込むと
居心地よいと思う人が多いかもしれませんが
いわばぬるま湯状態だと思います
でもぬるま湯状態に入ってしまうと
なかなか抜け出せないという要素が
ありますけれども
ぜひ そこには時には熱めのお湯
時には冷たい水に浸かることも
好きな人もいるかと思います
多様な感性を持つ人がいることによって
社会が変化に柔軟に対応できて
過ごしやすい社会に繋がるのでは
ないでしょうか？
ぜひ 勇気を持って
そのぬるま湯状態から飛び出して
多様性に溢れる世界に
飛び込んでいってほしいと思います
このために必要なのは 自分のルーツ[と]
自分が生まれた歴史背景をしっかりと知って
自分が誰なのかを
しっかりと自分と見つめ合うこと
そして隣の人との違いを知り
接点を持ちながら
いろいろと対話していくということ
そういうことによって 尊重し合える関係が
できるのではないでしょうか？
多くの人達は自分自身と向き合うチャンスが
ないとは思いますが
ぜひ自分達の多様性に
気づいていただきたいと思います
違っている者同士が強みを活かして
弱みを補うような信頼関係を築くことに
ぜひ仲間に入れていただきたいと思います
（拍手）